Alex, you put that gun down right now, or nobody's going to abandon YouTube.
How is YouTube gonna ban you when you have a gun out on your desk right now,
calm down as your media buyer. I have to tell, I have to advise you.
You can't be doing this right. You can't be doing this. Hang on,
hang on Alex. One second. I got it. All right. I gotta leave.
Sorry about that, boys.
Money's getting a little tight since we bought the $10 million studio.
Cashflow is not flowing in quite like I thought. Uh,
I guess I went a little ambitious with this crazy studio, so I apologize,
but picking up some extra shifts, uh, you know,
don't hate a guy for where he works, please guys. Today,
I want to talk about something that has nothing to do with old Jones today.
I want to talk about Jeff Bezos and the people take an advantage.
Ladies and gentlemen, welcome to just one scam.
That's what I'm titling this video today. We're talking about just one dime,
which is a company selling another Amazon automation course.
So we're going to decide, should you invest your money in this course?
How should you think about this course, guys? Now,
why am I qualified to tell you that? Right. Uh, you know,
am I some business expert, right? I mean,
you decide, you decide, it's just basically me,
Amazon and Dan Locke, the top three businessmen of our era. And uh,
yeah. So I am qualified to talk about it in case you were wondering,
absolutely have very serious business skills that are not a joke,
but we're just going to talk about common sense, risk management.
Because let me tell you guys everything.
This guy does is something that I like to call risk for the
none for me. Right? You want to stay away from these people.
These people want to saddle you with all the problems.
If anything goes upside down, right? Because if investments go well,
everyone's happy. Obviously, sometimes investments go, well,
sometimes they don't. Now what happens when things go sideways,
the people who were in Stephen mayor's course,
if you saw my last video on Amazon automation,
this guy ran off with $12 million. What are those people going to do? Right?
The downside happened. What are they going to do? Well, you might say Steven,
they'll just Sue. Yeah. Guess what Steven Mayer is going to do.
He's going to defend himself with the money that they paid him.
There are no lose, lose situation. They don't have any money.
Cause they already paid it to the scam. And now what are they gonna do?
They're gonna try to get it back,
how he's going to fight them with their own money.
So that's what you guys have to think about. What happens when things go bad,
pay attention to this guys,
because this guy's going to pretend like they're not like the other gurus.
They're different. Let's listen in.
Not sacrifice our credibility for money.
It takes years to build the credibility we have compared to all the so-called
gurus.
All right, stop right there.
These people need to stop saying I'm not like those other guys.
I'm totally different. They all say that right to hell. Say that.
Who claimed Amazon automation and all they want is the upfront feed.
Then be give a crap about you. You get, you can lose your reputation in five,
but let's just start.
With that. Right? Okay. No high fees, high fees upfront scam.
Because they're just trying to run away with you at the high fees. Well,
let's see. What did Steven Merrick charge? I think it was like $30,000.
So what's this guy charged. He must be charging a lot less, right?
Is $10,000 fee per product. Okay.
That does not include the cost of the product.
You have to pay $10,000 per product and you have to start
with three. So it's $30,000.
So your minimum upfront investment is 30,000 no less.
So you just criticize people with high fees. Cause you're like, Oh yeah,
they're just going to run away. And they don't care about you,
but then you're doing the exact same thing.
But maybe I just don't understand how much money you're going to be making.
I mean,
you must be balling if you're going to put in 30 K minimum plus product
costs, maybe another 10 K each puts you at 60 K all in. So you must,
must be making a lot of money. How much money you making Seth.
A conservative ROI. We've gone through the numbers.
So many times a conservative ROI within 12 months is
200%.
Woo. 200% interesting. Okay. Okay.
Seth, I'm listening.
Show me any real estate. Any stocks, anyone out there,
even for angel investors who get an ROI like that with this loan.
Risk now what's he basing this off of? He says he ran the numbers, right?
What's he basing this off of, I mean, is he making a guarantee.
Seth? Can you give me a guarantee? No. Okay.
Learning the numbers.
Your minimum ROI is around 200% mint in numb bum.
Is that not a guarantee? Wait, does that sound like a guarantee to you.
Running the numbers? Your minimum ROI is around 200%.
What number numbers? Your minimum ROI.
What numbers, Hey, what numbers.
Running the numbers?
Your minimum ROI is around 200% minimum, 500%.
A thousand percent like that's minimum within a year. Okay.
Which is insane that isn't saying,
compare that to where are you getting that from though? Additionally,
additionally, the chances of us failing at a product are so ridiculously slim.
It's not even funny for every 100 products. I launch.
Three of them are not as profitable as I hoped.
Three is that puts you in a pretty ridiculously good case.
Now let's just say worst case scenario. We've launched three. One of them fails.
You still make money. Why? Because this,
the success of the two more than makes up for the loss of the one.
But set. That's not the worst case, baby. Hey, am I crazy?
Or is the worst case scenario that three of them fail all three and then you're
left with nothing.
Worst case scenario. We've launched three. One of them fails.
Just not the worst case scenario and like sure.
You're giving a money back guarantee.
Are you so confident that you're giving a money back guarantee?
I Seth, can you give me a guarantee? No.
So all of that's annoying, but that's not what really me off. This is,
but that's just the beginning.
Of the fees. Let me explain all of them to you. Talk about transparency.
Here we go.
15% of total sales revenue due every three months goes to us.
Sales revenue boys. He's taking 15% of your sales revenue.
And I'll explain why we don't do profit. And it's actually in your favor.
It may not seem like that.
Let's watch him do that. Mental gymnastics again, dude.
It's like watching a gold medalist on the floor.
No explain why we don't do profit. And it's actually in your favorite.
May not seem like that. I will explain that in a minute.
Okay. Did you guys just hear that? So not only is he charging $30,000, right?
This guy, he says 200% minimum ROI, but if it doesn't happen, it's not on me.
Then he goes, okay, I'm charging you 15% of your revenue.
Meaning if you're making no money,
but you made a hundred thousand dollars in sales,
but you've spent it all on product and margins and all this kind of stuff. PBC,
guess what? You still have to pay him $15,000. That's right. Gentlemen,
Seth wants 15% of your money. Even if you're making no money at all.
And he says, that's in your favor. He goes, I was going to do profit,
but then I decided it's in your favor. Now watch this boys.
This stuff drives me crazy.
How do you justify the 15% revenue share? This seems high. Is this negotiable?
No, it is not negotiable.
Let me explain why we've been through this enough to know.
Let me just give you an example. When we first started this program,
we have the idea of doing a 30% net profit share.
And I know upfront that sounds better,
but it is better because we don't make money. Unless you make.
Money. It's a terrible decision. Either way,
30% is way too much of your profits, but okay. It's, it's better. Yeah.
And I get that and that was my original goal. But the more we did it,
the more I realized this is a problem. Let me give you an example.
Let's say we sell a hundred thousand dollars worth of these.
Let's just say your profit was a hundred thousand to keep it simple.
When do we get our 30,000? Because that back then it was 30,000. Now,
if we get it, now there's a problem because that means you have less money
to buy the next batch, which means your per unit cost will be greater.
Which means your margins will be thinner.
Wait, stop. He says,
I can't take away from your profits because then you wouldn't have enough money
to invest Seth you beautiful idiot.
Do you not understand that? If you take away from the sales revenue,
their margins will also be thinner. I mean,
I don't know if this guy is willfully while I know it's willfully. He's just,
he knows that taken away from revenues way worse for the customer,
but way better for him.
And he knows that the margins are going to be affected either way and
his whole problem of when do we take the money? Well,
the same question applies to when you take sales revenue,
what do you take it at the beginning before someone's profitable.
You could just replace exactly what he said was sales revenue.
It would make just as much sense.
All of this is a big fat distraction from the truth,
which is that there's no good reason for him to take from your sales revenue
zero,
but he wants to take from it anyway because it makes him more say it with me,
say it with me Monday. It makes him more my knee.
And he likes that like seriously,
it's so funny listening to this guy really struggle with the concept because
he's basically saying, Oh yeah, I couldn't fathom taking away from your profits.
That would be unfair. I mean, how could I do that to you?
When he's planning to take away from your sales revenue,
he could just do the same thing with the profits. It doesn't make any sense.
Again. Everything's for him to win. Even if he doesn't do his job. Even if Seth,
Seth, the boy, you know, if everything goes South,
because he screws up your store, does he lose? Does he not make his cashflow?
No. He still makes the baby.
And it's funny because this is the guy who's saying 200% minimum ROI. It is.
We ran a whole bunch of numbers. Oh my God said enough with the numbers, sir.
And we are erring on the side of you making more than if it was a 30% net
margin. Oh boy, let's go back.
margin,
you cannot believe that there's no way you believe that it airs on that side.
We've run it a hundred times every way. How,
how have you run it a hundred times? A hundred different ways. Listen,
it's actually very simple. All right.
If you charge 15% sales revenue versus 30% profit,
there's only one condition in which 30% net profit is worse for the
customer than 15% net revenue. You want to know what it is. Here's what it is.
If your profit margins are over 50%,
which is great for the customer, they're making money. They're happy.
Then it's better for them. If you're taking 30% revenue.
So if it dips below that, let's say it gets to 30%, right?
30% profit margins.
Guess what sets still takes is 15% cut.
And now your profits have been hacked.
He's taking an effective 50% cut of your profits.
So guess who it benefits again, I, again, this guy,
all the while,
he's trying to dupe you into believing that you're going to be making more
money. If you go this way, look at him. I ran it a hundred different ways.
What we've done it every way.
And we are erring on the side of you making more than if it was a 30% net
margin. It airs on that side.
We'd run it a hundred times every way he's done it every way, guys.
And he doesn't understand how the math works any other way.
It doesn't make any sense. Guys.
You have to understand that these people are not your friend.
They're not doing it for the good of humanity, right?
If they wanted to scale up their business,
this guy is all about scaling up his business. Then go take out a loan.
That's what it's called. It's called a loan. Think about the following facts.
Okay. He's saying that you're virtually no risk, right?
Because 97% of his products succeed.
They're just as profitable as he thought they were.
And he's also saying you have a minimum ROI of 200%, right?
So that means that he could do the same thing with the story of his own,
make 200% on his money. So let's say he goes out to a bank, right?
He goes into a bank, takes out a gigantic loan on 20% interest.
If it's a minimum ROI of 200%, no big deal. Right?
Cause he's still making money.
He's making all of the profit instead what he's saying, Hey,
I thought it was a better idea. If I partner with you guys, partner with you,
small investors, where you take the majority of the cut,
that doesn't make any sense. But I just want to add this part in,
I'm editing this in post. Cause I, I was watching the whole thing again.
And I wanted to say one thing that this guy does. Right? Okay.
Which is that he says that if you don't have the money, don't join.
I don't want you sending me the last pieces of money you have and going broke.
Don't do it. I criticize gurus all the time about this.
They always try to get everybody in this guy. He says,
if you don't have the money don't join. I did like that. Respect for that.
I think it's a terrible investment opportunity. That's just my opinion.
I think this guy has protected himself from every single downside.
All the while telling you that you need to risk every penny. Okay?
That's what he's doing.
But I'll say that at least he's not targeting poor people. So for that,
you get a coffee's a little one-star.
The thing is guys is with all of these programs, you have to be thinking,
what if it goes wrong? What if this guy who seems so charming?
He's smiling at me saying what a good guy. He is saying,
how much he cares about me. I care about you, buddy.
You gotta think what if this guy is lying to you?
What if he's not telling you the truth? What's your downside.
They stick you with all the risk. They stick you with all the problems.
They pretend to be so competent in their courses. But at the end of the day,
when you dig down, can you get your money back? No baby. No.
If they fail, that's on you. Even if they kind of flounder,
that's also on you because they'll take your sales revenue. Do what a joke.
Anyway, this is your daily reminder to not fall for the idiots.
Call the clowns out and dissolve.
Don't forget to smash like and subscribe. Thank you.
[inaudible].